Hello world.
It's a Raj and my demo today is landing
this space x rocket in a simulation
using machine learning.
This thing has learned how to properly
land using all of those gravitational
Constance balancing. It's weights,
velocity, physics, all these things,
but the key here is machine learning.
It's not rocket science.
It's machine learning,
which is even better.
So that's what we're going to do today.
I'm going to code this out.
It's going to be about
150 lines of python.
I'm going to be using the tensorflow
libraries, the tensorflow library,
and the open Ai Jim Library.
But before I get there,
we've got to learn a bit
about reinforcement learning
as a bit of background
before we get to the technique that
it uses, which is called stay with me,
proximal policy optimization.
I know that's a mouthful and
we're going to get there,
but first we've got to
learn some background on
reinforcement learning. Okay,
so open Ai. It was started
by Elan Musk, Sam Altman,
a bunch of really prominent people in the,
in the tech space.
But the goal was to build safe
AI in a way that was distributed,
that was open so everybody had access to
it in order to ensure a more beneficial
future for humanity.
And one of the major contributions
that open AI has made to the world is
releasing the gym environment.
So Jim is this really cool, uh,
library on get hub that allows
anybody to train their AI algorithms,
uh, in a bunch of different
environments. It's very cool.
A Universe was kind of
their next, um, environment,
which they hired me to make
a video on back in the day.
And then Ilan retweeted it.
It was awesome. But anyway,
that's a tangent. But Jim,
Jim is kind of what has stayed in the
mainstream university and really take off
for whatever reason. But, but Jim is still
there. It's, it's, it's still very active.
People are still using it
and a bunch of examples,
you can find it on get hub and they've
got a bunch of different environments
from Atari Games to three d simulations
using moo Joko at toy tax class control
a bunch of different examples, right?
So it's a collection of environments.
It's all in python and it's
really easy to use. The,
the whole point of it is so that you
don't have to focus on building the
environment.
You can just focus on the algorithm.
And they had this leaderboard
as well on the website,
but that they took that
down for whatever reason.
But you can still find a leaderboard
that compares the strength of different
algorithms on, on get hub. And it's
in this, uh, Jim Wikipedia page.
It was updated 25 days ago, but,
uh, I would still make a PR.
If you have some kind of
update and they're gonna,
they're likely going to accept
that, that request. Okay.
So let's start with reinforcement
learning. So this is right.
So there are different ways that we can
class the learning experience, right?
Supervised unsupervised reinforcement
online, offline. You know,
there's, there's a million different
ways that we can class learning,
but anytime that we have some
kind of time element, right?
So when we add the element of time,
which is where an
environment comes into play,
that's when we can use reinforcement
learning. It's a computational approach.
We're an agent,
interacts with an environment by taking
actions where it tries to maximize a
reward. So this is a very
simple way of visualizing this.
We have an agent that is a Bot, an
AI, a person, an animal, a human.
Anything that takes an
action in the environment.
If it's learning how to ride a bike,
that action would be to
push down on the pedal.
The environment will then update by
giving it a reward, right? So if, if I,
if I push successfully,
then my muscle won't have any pain.
So my brain is getting that reward back,
right?
And I've updated the states
in my environment, my, my
foot is now lower and this,
this just repeats over and over again.
But if I push in the wrong
direction or my, you know,
my foot goes just crazy
in a different direction,
then I'm going to get a negative reward
and I want to avoid that negative reward.
So a much more formal mathematical way
of describing this agent environment loop
is to describe it as what's called
a mark Hoff decision process.
This is based off of Andre
Markoff and early mathematicians.
Initial principle to mark off property,
but essentially it's a way of estimating
probabilities and how they change over
time in an environment.
So we have a state,
a state is how you, an agent is
currently in a game. Like what,
what's its position, what's
its move, what's it's uh, the,
the way it's positioned in relation
to other objects in the environment.
And then we have an action.
This could be, you know,
punching a wall or hitting a ping
pong ball or jumping up and down.
It's something that the agent does.
We have a transition probability that
that relates the states to the action.
We have a reward, which is what the
agent receives if the action was correct.
So by correct I'm saying how
does it affect the objective?
What is the objective of the game to win,
to lose?
How does it affect it if it's uh,
if it's a winning move,
if it's a winning action, then the
reward will be something like a plus one.
If it's not,
it's a minus one.
And there are different quantities
that are involved here, like policies,
utilities, Q values, and that's there.
There's a lot that we can go into.
There's so many different ways and
pathways we can go into when we're talking
about reinforcement learning.
But what the one that I want to
focus on is the policy and the value,
which I'm going to go into in a second.
But before we get into that,
let's talk about offline
and online learning.
Remember I said there's so many different
ways that we can class though the
different learning processes and
one way is offline versus online.
So online just means learning in
real time as we're playing the game,
which is what we're going to do and
offline is before or after or in between
games.
So it's like we've already completed a
set of actions in an environment we're
done and now we're learning from that.
Whereas online is during the
actual process of interacting.
That's what we're going to do.
So to summarize a bit about Arele,
we have an agent.
It interacts with an environment and
it learns what's called a policy.
So this is a very important word.
We have a state and an action.
And a policy describes how an agent
decides how to best interact with the
environment using its current state and
the list of potential actions it could
take, right? So it, it looks at what's
called the state transition matrix,
which relates all the states to all the
actions. And the policy says, what's the,
what's the optimal action I can take
right now that will maximize my goal,
right? How do I get to my goal in the
most efficient, optimal way possible?
And the policy will tell the
agent exactly how to do that.
But in addition to the policy, there's
also another feature called the value,
what's called the value function.
So the value function will evaluate
every single possible move and it will
create this list of all the
possible values for every move.
And it will choose what
that best value is.
The policy uses the value function
to then evaluate every move.
So the value function is saying,
this move is, this is this good,
this movie is this bad, this movie,
this is even better. And then the,
and then the policy will use that value
function to then pick the best move.
So the value function
is a part of the policy.
The policy is the higher order function
on top of the value function and this
value function can be learned
and approximated by any
learning and approximation
approach like in our case, a neural
network, right? Function approximation.
So we're going to learn about you
function and it's going to help us learn a
policy and we can broadly
categorize reinforcement
learning into three different
groups. For our sake, right now for
approximate policy optimization,
there is the critic only method where we
first learn about you function and then
use that to define a policy,
right?
We we learn a value function using a
neural network and then use that to define
the policy.
Then there's an actor only method where
we directly searched the policy space.
We don't have this.
The policy is what's evaluating
all the moves without separating.
These modules have a value and a policy
function, you know, independently.
And then there's an actor critic method.
This is where we have two
different neural networks.
One learns the value and one learns
the policy, right? So the cue,
the critic observes the actor
and evaluates its policy,
determining when it needs to change.
So the critical be a neural network.
The actor will be a neural network.
The actor will then take action in the
environment and then the state will be
returned to both the actor and the
critics, the critical observe this,
the new states, and then
send, it's a Q value,
which is the quality of that action
to the actor so that it can update its
weights.
And the process repeats.
And what's what's been found is to have
to do is when we have two different
neural networks,
an actor and a critic,
this usually outperforms both
acthar only and critic only methods.
So we're getting closer to proximal policy
optimization. Let's keep going here.
So there's this idea of the
policy gradient approach.
Andre Carpathia has a
great blog post on this,
and I'll link to it in the description,
but the idea is that,
let's say we're in a game,
right?
Let's say we're in Pong and we're trying
to evaluate how good each move is,
right?
Let's say one of the moves is moving
the paddle up and then the ball hits the
paddle and then it goes to the opponent.
Well, one, one thing you could say is,
well, this was good, right? So returning
to reward of plus one, but the problem is,
what if that's move was good in the short
term, but it was bad in the long term.
What if it was better to move the
pedal down? The ball would go down,
the agent would hit, the opponent
would hit it. You hit it again,
and then you were let more likely to
win the game. If you would've went down,
then you went up. If you just
updated your weights immediately,
you wouldn't have known that you,
instead,
you should wait until the game is finished
before evaluating how good that move
was. And that's where the policy
gradient approach comes in.
It waits for the game to finish for
the episode to finish before using that
result as a gradient to
then update the weights.
So it's kind of like supervised learning
where the label is the result, right?
The log probability of whether or
not that action was good or bad,
and then updating the weights. So that's
the policy gradient method. So now,
now on top of that,
there's something called the trust
region policy optimization method.
This is the same idea as
the policy gradient method,
except it doesn't stray too
far from the old policy.
So one of the downsides of the policy
gradient method is that sometimes updates
are way too big and this causes a lot
of noise in the loss function and it,
and it prevents the, the network
from, from converging on the,
on the proper optimization scheme.
So what the trp Oh method does is it says,
let's not stray too far
from the old policy.
Stay near to the old policy making
too large a change is a bad thing.
So how do we do this?
Well,
a naive solution is to make
a very small step every time.
But then how do you take small steps?
What trp Oh does is it controls the
rate of policy change using a constraint
then then comes PPO, right?
So Ppo proximate policy,
implement optimization is an
implementation of trp. Oh,
that adds what's called a KL divergence
term to training the loss function.
And so there's a,
there's a,
there's a KL divergence term
that trains the loss function,
and there's also one that updates
the old policies. So check this out.
Here's what the graph looks like for what
we're going to build in what's called
tensor born. We have a po, we haven't
fault, we have a policy function,
we have a old policy function,
we have an, we have a critic,
and the actor or the actor is going
to be this policy function, okay?
This is gonna make a lot more
sense when I start coding it,
but just recognize that we have
what's called an actor, a critic,
and this is an implementation of what's
called proximate policy optimization.
All right,
so let's get to the code.
So the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to import tensorflow, right?
These are our,
this is our machine learning library,
and we're going to import gym.
And then we're going to go ahead and
create this PPO class, right? This,
this is where our main object is going
to be that we're going to use later on.
Now we're going to initialize it and
it via our python in it function.
Go Python. Now, who's ready for this?
The first thing we're going to do is
initialize our tensor flow session as a TF
dot session, right? This allows us
to execute graphs or part of graphs.
This is the tensor flow
graph, right? The, the,
the main part of our pipeline that we're
going to place all of our objects into.
Then we're going to create a place holder.
This is just a variable that we will
later assign data too at some point.
But right now it's going to be a float
32 object, um, the size of the tensor,
or he's going to be none.
Give it some hyper parameter that I've,
that I'm going to define later, and then
it's going to be called the state. Okay?
Now we're ready to define our critic.
Okay,
so this critic is going
to be a neural network.
So we're gonna use
tensorflow is variable scope.
So the variable scope keyword is it allows
us to create new variables and to to
share already created ones.
So this is just a way of organizing
our code of a a bit better.
So the first layer of our network,
we're going to use the layers sub module
and it's going to be a dense layer
because every single note in the first
layer is going to be connected to the
next layer. We're going to use that.
That's a placeholder as a data entry.
It's a gateway for data into the network.
And then we're going to say the uh,
nonlinearity is going to
be called [inaudible],
which is a very popular nonlinear function
that makes sure our network can learn
both linear and nonlinear functions.
Remember,
neural networks are universal
function approximators. Now, well,
let's create our value, right?
So the value is going to be, uh,
this dense layer and it's going to be
the output of the first layer is going to
be fed into this value variable.
Now we're going to create
a discounted reward.
This is a reward in the future that's
not worth quite as much as the reward
right now. And we'll say, okay, this
is two is going to be a place holder.
Okay.
TF,
Daf float,
the size,
we'll keep it small and we're going to
call it discounted reward to keep things,
keep things, um, organized.
And I'll call it discounted reward.
Now,
uh,
all right, so now the advantage, this
is the next variable we're going to use.
It's called the advantage.
So we'll say the ta,
the advantage is going to
be the difference between
the discounter to award and
the value.
And so the basically this estimates
rather than just discounted returns,
it allows the agent to determine not
just how good a its actions were,
but how much better they
turned out to be than expected.
And this should be a minus,
not an equals. There we go.
Now for our loss function.
So our loss function is going to,
uh, minimize that
advantage over time, right?
We want to make sure that advantage gets
smaller and smaller. So our expected, uh,
action is going to be closer
and closer to what the real,
the optimal action should be.
And it's the mean squared error.
That's why we're using these
functions right here. And lastly,
we're going to make sure to use
gradient descent because wine,
because grading dissent is
the most popular optimization
strategy out there for
neural networks. And one
implementation of that is called Adam.
And I've got a great video on Adam.
If you just want to check out, um,
what's it called?
Which activation function should you use?
I talk about the difference between
Adam and nesteroff momentum and so many
different amazing activation functions
using that loss function as his parameter.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that's our critic.
We've got our critic, uh,
everybody's a critic these days,
right? So now we're going to go
into our actor, the actor himself,
Nicolas Cage,
because he's on the Internet.
So the actor is going to be our
policy network by the way. Okay.
So the actor's going to be our policy
network and our critic is actually our
value network. I forgot to mention that
part. So the critic is the value network.
And the actor's going to
be the policy networks.
So we separate these two concepts
into a different, different modules.
So for our actor, we're going to say,
okay, it's going to return the, uh,
normal distribution of actions
and then the trainable parameters.
But I'm going to go ahead and have a,
uh,
simple helper function for this to
build a very similar neural network.
I'll call it pie. Uh, and then
I'll say yes, it is trainable,
was very similar to one layer neural
network, which I can define later.
And so now what? Remember, we want
to have two different policies.
We have an old policy, and then we
have a newer policy. So I'll say,
let's have the same exact outputs
and we'll use the same exact,
uh,
help her function,
except we'll call this one the old policy.
And then this one's not
going to be trainable
now for our, uh, for us
to sample our actions.
Now the next thing we want to do is we
want to sample our actions from both the
old and the new policy networks
so we can compare them. So again, we're
gonna use that variable scope, uh,
function to then sample actions.
Okay.
And we say, we're going to say, okay,
so the sample operation is going to use,
uh,
this TF dot squeeze function.
And then we're going to sample from it.
Okay.
And the access is going to be zero
because we don't want multiple dimensions.
And this is basically just going to choose
an action from, from our distribution,
right? So it's going to output
a distribution of possible
actions we could take.
That's what the neural net
learns for the Policy Network.
And then we're going to just
choose an action from that.
And then we're gonna say, okay, so
that's, that was a sample action.
And now we want to have a,
another variable scope.
We'll call this one the
update the old policy.
This one's going to update the old policy.
So then we'll just call it update old P,
I.
Okay.
And we'll say, okay, update old policy
cold p. Dot. Assign p four,
p, O p and zip. And then we
have those, the new policies,
parameters.
Okay.
No. Okay. So that's it for our s for
us sampling from the actions from both.
Now we can, uh, create two placeholders.
So these are going to be placeholders
for the action and the advantage.
And we're gonna use these to help us
compute our loss functions in a second.
So we'll say,
okay,
so the action stuff that Tfa
is going to be a place holder,
not a hotline or a holder. This
is not bitcoin. A placeholder,
TF dot float 32.
It's going to be very similar size and
it's going to be called the action.
And I'll just copy and paste it again
because it's a very similar line.
And this time it's going
to be called the advantage.
How's that TF advantage? And
this is going to be one. Okay.
So now we have these placeholders
and now we can finally say, let's
do cuts, computer lost functions.
So again, variable Dusko
scope. Notice how I'm,
I'm putting all of my modules
inside of this variable scope.
And another reason this is useful is
because in the tensor flow graph we are
able to name these things so
we can see how all of these uh,
tenters are flowing through the nodes.
In the computation graph that we
create inside of our loss function,
we're going to have something called a
surrogate. Okay. So you might be thinking,
what the hell is a surrogate?
So this is actually really interesting.
So let me show you this.
So a surrogate is,
so when it comes to sometimes in machine
learning, the air surface doesn't,
isn't very smooth, right? So if you think
of gradient descent as dropping a ball,
dropping a ball into a bowl, and then
having that ball find the minimum.
So that's easy if the
air surface is curved,
but sometimes it's noncontinuous.
So this is some discrete math for you,
but sometimes it's surface doesn't just
easily go from one range to another.
It's not smooth. It looks
more like this, right?
So the ball won't just
flow down to the minimum.
It's going to hit different steps.
It's going to go all over the place.
So we want to make sure that air surface
is continuous, that it's very flat,
that it's smooth,
that we can easily find the gradient.
And to do that we'll create two loss
functions. We have a loss function,
and then we have a loss function for
the loss function and we call this a
surrogate loss function and that
the surrogate loss function,
we'll first smooth out that earth's
surface and then we can find the minimum,
which I think is very cool.
All right,
we're going to use these two
terms to compute the k l penalty.
So the Kale by the way
stands for Ku Black Liebler,
two guys in the in like back in the day,
a couple of decades ago,
who discovered a really
cool loss function.
It's used a lot in generative adversarial
networks and in proximate policy
optimization. But basically let's
go, let's go. Let's check this out.
So the both of these two terms,
the the ratio and the surrogates will
help us compute a kal Penn a penalty.
And what's going to happen is we're
going to use the old policy and the new
policy to come to compute the
Kale divergence between both.
We'll take that Kale divergence term,
get the mean,
and then compute a loss
using the surrogate.
So then we're going to find the difference
between the surrogates and the lambda
that we just computed times that Kale
divergence term and that's going to give
us a loss function.
We will minimize that loss
function using gradient descent.
So these are the two separate distinct
respective loss functions that we're
minimizing, one for the policy
and one for the value network,
which will also calling the
actor and the critic network.
We can then write all of that to
disk and then run the session.
So I actually want to show you
some of the helper methods as well.
That's the base code for
creating the policy and the uh,
value networks. But let's look at
some of the helper methods as well.
So for the build a net function
that I talked about, this is it,
it's just a single layer neural network.
We compute a mean and a an a sigma.
And then we use that to compute a normal
distribution and return that as well as
the other parameters, the global
variables, but in the training loop,
here's, here's the real, the real magic
where we implement what we just created.
We'll say, let's start our training
loop, create an initial environment.
We'll have a buffer for both the states,
the actions and the rewards,
and in a single episode we'll use the
PPO class we just created to choose the
best action dependent on the state and
that's going to return that action.
Now we'll take that action and then
execute that in the environment using the
step function really easy part of using
a open Ai's gym and that's going to
return the state, the reward,
and then whether or not
we're done and some log, uh,
criteria which are not actually using.
We'll add all three of those to our
buffers and then will compute the total
reward over time. Then we update
our PPO object. We'll say, well,
let's get that value that get the using
the states and then get the discounted
reward.
Then finally we're going to,
we're going to pop all of those off the
stack and then update our policy using
those that that new state,
that new action and that
new reward and that's it.
Then we can render the environment and
then display the frames as a gift for
whatever we want to and return all
those rewards at the very, very end.
This is the training loop where you run
it for a set number of epochs and then
eventually what's going to happen is that
rocket is going to use both the policy
and the value networks,
the actor and the critic to learn what's
the best way to land on that landing
pad, right? It's going to say if it
doesn't land, it's a minus one, right?
If it does lend, it's a plus one and it
can use all of these different methods.
Turn left, turn right,
turn up, go move faster,
move slower on its booster,
and then there's a bunch
of other gravitational
constants that are in the that
environment set up for it that we,
you can see in the documentation
I'm going to give you.
Basically it's going to use
all of those to learn. Well,
what's the best way to try all this out?
The policy is computing
these stochastically that is,
it's using a distribution to sample
from all the possible actions.
And the value function is going
to say, well here are, here's the,
here's how I'm going to rate
all of these possible actions.
And the policy will say,
Hey, value function.
I see how you're rating all of these
possible actions and I'm going to learn
from you.
And the value functions learning as well.
So there are two different sets of
gradients that are being composed that are
being computed over time and eventually
through that plus one minus one feedback
loop that we're getting from
open Ai's gym environment.
These two networks going to work together
to help this thing land as efficiently
as possible, right? So we can say, um,
by Felon Ppo dot pie. And then
we can see it run just like that.
So this thing is,
this is a trained a version
of the algorithm. If you
want to train it yourself,
I've got the source code in
the description, check it
out. It's the get hub link.
And hope you liked this video, please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to get a seat on
the falcon heavy, so thanks for watching.